it's so infuriated that this was allowed
to go on as long as it did George
Clooney speaks out on the allegations of
three decades of sexual harassment
against Harvey Weinstein why he's hoping
the aftermath brings change to Hollywood
there has to be something good that's
gonna come out of all of this and the
thing that's good that could come out of
this is that wouldn't feel safer in
talking about these situations and in
doing so then it makes it much harder
for men who would behave like this to do
it you know Harvey would talk about
women that he you know gone out with him
I didn't really necessarily believe that
cuz to believe that would believe some
bad things about actresses that I know
and like and I didn't really buy into
that but I will say that somebody knew
and if there was a reporter that sat on
the story for years and didn't write it
I want to know why because I would have
liked to have known these stories and
and if there was someone if there was a
newspaper or a website that didn't that
had this information that investigated
it I'd like to see how much ad money
they got from
Miramax or for the Moines become I want
to know who took women up to a hotel
room and then left them there for Harvey
I want to know who did that Harvey's
gonna get his you know and it's gonna
and it and it deserves it but there's
other people involved in this and I will
you know
the whole culture of this is gonna have
the stuff and this isn't just show
business this was Fox News is you know
it's in DC clearly it's it's everywhere
my wife who's a human rights lawyer says
that you know she's faced those exact
kinds of situations in law yeah so it's
not just you know it's it's everywhere
and so it needs to be addressed as if
it's a problem for all of us and we have
to we have to take it on full force
[Music]